we have some more big changes coming to
not just Marvel Studios but Marvel in
general how's it going everybody it's
Warren and we knew that when Kevin Feige
was announced CCO chief creative officer
of Marvel Entertainment not just Marvel
Studios again but Marvel Entertainment
we knew that there was going to be some
changes and today's changes have a big
impact on the MCU not just with the
film's not just with the Disney Plus
shows as well but with the TV shows that
could be coming out as well and this
could mean some pretty big changes for
the MCU and some of your favorite
characters as well so let's talk about
this news and let's talk about what
exactly it means for the future of the
MCU and the future of some of your
favorite characters if you're new to my
channel be sure to subscribe I'm doing
an xbox one and a ps4 giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and like the video and leave a comment
below with your favorite superhero or
villain so The Hollywood Reporter com
has just reported that Marvel television
head Jeff lobe is out at Marvel
Entertainment after nearly a decade long
run and this is actually extremely big
news if you are a fan of the MCU and if
you are a fan of the TV shows as well
because this actually has a very big
impact on both the MCU and the TV shows
and I'll explain exactly why Jeff Loeb
is the person who led Marvel
Entertainment into the live-action shows
Jeff is actually the person who steered
Marvel into live-action scripted TV
originals with ABC's agents of shield so
he has definitely done some work that we
should be grateful for however when Jeff
flew up was overseeing the TV shows they
were really treated as a separate entity
from Marvel and this is really why you
never saw any of the TV show characters
in the Marvel movies in the MCU this is
why there was sort of a division line
between the TV shows and the films but
now that Kevin Feige has been promoted
to chief creative officer over Marvel
Loeb's Marvel TV and the animation
focused Marvel family entertainment have
moved under Kevin feige's Marvel Studios
banner and this effectively knocks down
that wall that existed between the TV
shows and the MCU films and this is an
insanely good thing because now Kevin
Feige is essentially in charge over
everything and there's a big reason why
Marvel Studios decided to do that while
many fans did in
Jois several of the Marvel TV shows they
were not nearly as successful as any of
the MCU films most shows didn't rate
that well and many of the shows either
got cut or some of the seasons got
canceled while in the meantime the MCU
absolutely crushed it Kevin Feige led
the MCU into its first Best Picture
nomination for black panther and it's
record-breaking Avengers in-game box
office run and then when the Disney Plus
streaming service came out they turned
to Kevin Feige to lead the Disney Plus
shows Kevin Feige was not over TV shows
at this point in time just the MCU films
but even before he was announced the
chief creative officer Disney Plus
turned to him to do their TV shows which
really says a lot about how powerful
Kevin Feige really is and now Kevin
Feige has complete creative ability and
there is no more separation between the
TV shows and the movies and this opens
up everything not only for many
different characters to appear in the
MCU but also to appear in Disney Plus
shows and in regular TV shows as well
but have them all directly connect to
the MCU so the biggest part of this news
what it's really saying is that now the
Marvel Universe just got insanely bigger
and it can all connect there's no more
having separate different TV shows
Disney Plus shows and movies exist in
all of these different universes the
Inhumans that offenders Jessica Jones
Luke Cage iron fist daredevil the agents
of shield they can all exist in the same
universe now and they can all cross over
with each other and of course now they
are in the best possible hands that they
could be in Kevin Feige geez
so the Marvel Universe just got a lot
bigger and it could possibly start to
include some of your favorite characters
that you've been missing for some time
this definitely gives us hope for those
characters that we've missed like the
Inhumans Jessica Jones The Punisher
daredevil not only could they appear in
the MCU films now but their TV shows
could come back as well and if they did
make a return they would be in the hands
of Kevin Feige so let me know what you
think about this news the wall between
the TV shows and the MCU films has
officially been broken and now
everything is in the hands of Kevin
Feige so let me know what you think
about this in the comments down below
also don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to my channel so you can enter
my giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
one or a ps4 and so you can stay up to
date on everything relating to the MCU
as always thank you all so much for
watching well
off